Suecia acelera sus esfuerzos para
ingresar a la otan este jueves el
ministro de exteriores sueco anunció
progresos después de reunirse con su
homólogo Turco en presencia del
secretario general de la alianza
progresos que retomarán el presidente de
Turquía receptahipertogán y el Primer
Ministro de Suecia ulf kristerson en un
cara a cara
estamos trabajando muy intensamente para
convertirnos en miembros de la otan
esperamos una decisión positiva la
próxima semana Pero por supuesto lo
quiero subrayar esto es una decisión de
Turquía al final
el jefe de la otan Se declaró confiado
de que ankara retire el veto contra
estocolmo antes del inicio de la Cumbre
de la organización militar el martes en
Vilma
Suecia ha reformado su Constitución ha
introducido nuevas leyes antiterroristas
ha eliminado las restricciones de
exportaciones de armas a Turquía y en la
cooperación antiterrorista incluido el
pkka
como principal condición para levantar
su bloqueo Turquía Pide a Suecia la
extradición de personas kurdas a las que
acusa de terrorismo
Suecia hizo cambios en la lucha contra
el terrorismo que entraron en vigor el 1
de junio sin embargo ahora los cambios
tienen que ponerse en práctica si la
semana próxima Suecia logra que ankara
levante su veto se encaminaría a
convertirse en el miembro número 32 de
la alianza después de que Finlandia el
país con quien inició el proceso a raíz
de la invasión rusa de Ucrania integrar
a la otan el pasado mes de abril